- Hey man, how's it going?
- Good, how's it going with you?
- Ah good, how's it going with you?
Oh my gosh.
What the hell was that Zack?
You asked him how's it
going, he said good.
He asked you how's it
going, you said good,
then you said how's it going again.
You asked him twice, dude.
Do you even think before you talk?
Now he totally knows that
you weren't listening
the whole time, and you were
just going through the motions.
Look Zack I know it's a Wednesday,
we all go through the motions,
but get your act together man.
Hopefully he didn't notice,
but guess what everybody in the world
probably noticed how dumb you are Zack.
Honestly I'm embarrassed to
be your conscience right now.
You suck.
You should just quit
your job Zack, move away.
You don't deserve friends,
you don't deserve family,
you don't deserve girls.
Just get out of here.
What are you doing?
You're worthless.
- I'm good man.
- Oh, good.
- Oh, happy belated birthday by the way.
- Ah you too man.
(dramatic music)